[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We are really excited
for our guest, Hans Florine,
to here today.
He's come a long way from
Lafayette, California.
So, long way, depending on
the time of day, the traffic.
So Hans, just a
couple stats on Hans.
He's the world's
speed record holder
for climbing the
nose of El Capitan.
He did it with Alex
Honnold, not too long ago.
He is a three time
x-games champion
and holds many other
national championship
records and global
championship records,
which I'm sure he'll share.
So this is a guy who's
pushed the limits
on the sport of
climbing beyond what
people thought it could go.
What a perfect guest
for Google, who
are pushing the limits on
where technology is going.
And he does it with a
great humility as well,
and we'd like to think that
we have some humility also.
So with that, I'm going to
welcome Hans to the stage,
and let's give him a
big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
HANS FLORINE: I think I'm good.
We got great audio.
Wow, thanks.
I'm honored to be here.
Anybody here, show of
hands, seen me speak before?
I mean live.
Yeah?
Where did you see me speak?
AUDIENCE: It was probably
in the Simi Valley.
HANS FLORINE: Oh,
excellent, my home.
So I want to be a great
speaker for you guys,
and entertain you,
and all that stuff.
But I want to tell you
what I'm going to tell you,
and then I'll tell you it.
I'm going to just share.
I'm not going to Google
into, like hey, I
did this thing really
fast, and then you guys--
I don't know, Moore's law.
You've doubled the number of
zeros and ones on a silicon
chip or something every--
is it three and a half years
or is it 17 months?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: One and a half.
HANS FLORINE: There we go.
We'll do trivia
during this thing.
So it's one and a half years.
But this is my playground.
It's the second most
beautiful place on the planet.
That's right, so you guys can
do audience participation.
What's the first?
Of course, Mountain View is
the first most beautiful place.
[LAUGHTER]
Or the Google campus, right?
But this is kind of my
playground, or my lab,
or whatever you might
want to call it.
And this is El Capitan,
here on the left.
A lot of people
think Yosemite is
all about that little boulder
back there, half dome.
It is the most photoed
rock in the world.
Half dome in the
back, but my stories
will mostly be about El Cap.
And something that has kind
of made me go out and speak
a little bit more is that I
climbed the nose route, which
happens to be the sun's shadow
line up the center of El Cap,
for my hundredth
time a year ago.
Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
So, the nose root of El Cap is
the Everest of rock climbing.
Most climbers will
aspire to do it once.
Most mountaineers would
aspire to do Everest once.
So why on earth would I do it
100-- now 103 times, actually?
My co-author, Jamie, has done
all the beautiful writing,
and she's the one who basically
answers the question, why
would someone do that?
This presentation is not
about the book or anything,
it's more about just fun tales
of the history of climbing.
How the world of climbing fits
into Yosemite and leading on up
to a lot about me, of course,
and my history of climbing.
One of my sponsors of
outdoor research did this
because everyone's--
I'm very much into
numbers, myself,
and I think there's some
important things in here.
That 11 bails,
that means I failed
to climb the nose 11 times
in those first 100 attempts.
I don't know how many times
Sergey and Larry failed
to do the search engine
correctly, or whatever,
but I'm sure it was
far more than 11 times,
and that will probably be
my only tie-in to Google.
There's a lot of
mainstream questions
people ask, like how do you
go to the bathroom up there?
This is 76 WAG
bags, we call them.
I am very fast on El
Cap, but I've actually
spent 39 nights,
or 39 divvies, we
call him, on the route over
the 100 times I've done.
I've climbed it with 88
different people, now.
The oldest person
I climbed it with
was a 62-year-old and
the youngest, an 11
and 12-year-old boy and girl.
40 haul bags.
25 Cups of coffee.
I'm usually going so fast,
I can't drink coffee.
This is to get home afterwards
or to get to the base.
So I do talks all over and I
like to kind of show people
referentially where it is.
Show of hands here, how
many people have never
been to Yosemite, the
second most beautiful place
on the planet?
You guys, does anyone know?
It's probably three hours and
37 and a half minutes from here,
from the Google campus.
From my house it's
310 with a potty stop.
This is really cool.
It is not high altitude.
I'm a t-shirt and
shorts climber.
4,000 feet at the
base, only like 9,
10 at the height of the rim.
But because it changes
altitudes so quickly,
you actually can not only
climb through the clouds,
you can hike through it.
Anybody here climb
back a half dome?
Cool.
Did you do it with a permit?
Or did you kind of
black market it before--
AUDIENCE: I did Snake
Dike [INAUDIBLE].
HANS FLORINE: Oh,
Snake Dike, nice job.
So I mean, incredible.
I'm like a great guide,
real estate person
to sell you on going to Yosemite
if you haven't been there
before.
I climbed for 10
years in Yosemite
and didn't know that
this existed, that it
snowed in the winter there.
Because I was, like I said,
a t-shirt and shorts climber.
But there's a little badger
pass ski resort there.
It's $79 for a season
pass if you're under 14.
So all you parents out there,
it's a great place to learn.
One of the things that I
point out about Yosemite
is this 3,000 foot wall, there
are other 3,000 foot walls
in the world, but
you either need
to take a float plane or
a boat in Baffin Island
to get to them,
or a yak and maybe
a Russian helicopter in
the [INAUDIBLE] region
to get to it.
In Yosemite, you can park
right here and 15 minutes
from your car door,
you can place your hand
at the base of El Cap.
I mean, super accessible this
places is, is what I call it.
Super wild and--
[LAUGHTER]
I purposely use this photo where
there's jet trails in the sky,
to kind of make it-- it is this
odd thing of crazy wild terrain
and super accessible.
So those people who haven't been
to Yosemite, brace yourself.
This does not exist.
These buildings aren't there.
Just a reference, right.
So the tallest building in
the world, the Burj Khalifa,
or the Dubai tower, would
reach right about there.
Right So the tallest
structure humans
have made is still
not as tall as El Cap.
I know there's a Google--
what do they call it?
Point of view thing?
Street View, they did a Street
View up the nose of El Cap.
How many people have seen that?
Great, so it's all going to
be just rehash from that.
I'm going to just--
but it's incredible, right?
I'll go to Seattle and I'll
place El Cap in their city
as opposed to putting
buildings superimposed.
It's just crazy that the
spire is way down here
and El Cap would just be
towering over these things.
So definitely some
place you've got to go.
So the history of
climbing in Yosemite.
Anyone here, show of
hands, know the first year
Everest was ascended?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HANS FLORINE: '53, Yeah.
You know, this is so funny.
I was just thinking
you guys have
got to put your phones away
because you guys could Google
everything really quick and get
the answers to all my trivia
questions, but it is 1953.
And why I asked that
is because that's
the prize of the climbing world,
the tallest peak in the world.
Or maybe the hardest
thing that you
could do in climbing
is the tallest
peak in the world, which
is true in some regard.
So
When did they first climb this
iconic face, this 1,900 foot
face?
Was it before or after Everest?
It happened to be after, 1956.
They didn't think that you
could get enough gear, food,
red wine, whatever, up
this thing to survive.
I just kind of throw a
quick picture of the 50s,
60s here, to kind of make it
a point that they didn't have
an REI that you
could-- actually,
REIs opened in the
30s or 40s, but they
didn't have all the
gear that they have now.
This was the Northwest
regular route of Half Dome.
It took them five days
to climb this route.
A guy named Warren Hardy, no
relation to the president,
hiked around the back.
Was known to congratulate
them and then say,
I've got to do something
better to outdo you guys.
So he said, I'm going to
climb the face of El Cap,
which Half Dome would
only reach right here.
So Warren Hardy didn't
spend five days,
didn't spend 10 days, he
spent 33 days on this wall
and he got to right about here.
And the Park
Service said, you've
got to take all that rope,
gear, everything down
or go up and top
out, die trying.
So two years later,
1958, November 1st.
He went on the wall
with Jerry Gaulois--
excuse me, George
Whitmore and Wayne Merry.
And they spent 12
more days on route,
and they topped
out on this route,
and it's now called
the nose route.
It's the most sought after
big wall route in the world.
32-- I want to say bit, but
32 pitches or 32 rope lengths
long.
And people come from
around the world
to do this big wall route.
It's the number one
big wall route to do.
And I want to throw out like
images from the early 60s
and 50s.
Imagine these guys to get gear
to climb these walls in the 40s
and 50s.
They would go to junkyards,
saw the legs off of stoves,
drill holes in them, and
then hammer these things
into cracks.
They didn't have pitons
until mid late 50s,
and Chouinard from Patagonia
was making these things
as a blacksmith in his backyard,
and people were buying out
of the back of his truck.
This is pretty wild, 1960.
The second ascent of the
nose, they found this oil can.
Smelled like red wine because
that's what Warren Harding used
to bring up the stuff.
They didn't have
plastic bottles, per se.
It looks like there's only
maybe one or two people in here
as old as me.
They had plastic
chemistry bottles
back in the 50s
and 60s, but they
would cost $20, which would
be about like $200 today.
So they would find anything
they could to haul water up in.
And this is pretty interesting.
In his other hand, nothing
has changed in 60 years.
That's a Ghiradelli
chocolate bar.
That's Joe Fitch in there.
So I point out this thing,
and if I could, I don't know--
the leg off the
bottom of a stove
is probably an IBM
punch card, right?
Then you get pitons,
which would be something--
I don't know, this might be
not quite an Apple 2E yet.
But slowly, by the late 60s,
you had something as simple
as wedge shaped piece of metal,
which we call a nut or a chalk,
which you can just
slide into a crack.
And now you have these
aluminum aircraft devices,
and you guys can come up and
play with these if you want.
But you can pull this trigger
and this thing collapses,
small goes into
a crack, and then
you can hang a VW
bus off it, which
is the climber's car of choice.
And then pull the
trigger and it's out.
But imagine hammering
a piton 15 times,
and then someone
comes up behind you
because you're doing a
bunch of pitches in a row,
they have to hammer it out.
So a lot different.
The technology of how
to climb these things
has changed over the decades.
This picture is Mission Cliffs.
It's a climbing gym
in San Francisco.
And why I put this
in here is that Royal
Robbins, Tom Frost,
Warren Harding,
they didn't climb
during the winter.
They were ski bums
So now you have 12
month a year climbers.
And of course, there's
culture behind it now.
Back then you were kind of a
beatnik, loser, outskirts sort
of thing.
Now you might as well be playing
football as you are climbing,
it's so popular.
We're in the Olympics, 2020.
So I can't resist
a x-games thing
that came around in the 90s.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CHEERING]
- Already you can see Lowe's
feet are all over the place.
[INAUDIBLE] mostly
with his upper body,
I think that's hurting
him because his arms are
doing all of the work.
Whereas Hans, really
precise with his feet,
letting his legs propel
him up that wall.
- Florine again looking to
conserve some energy as--
HANS FLORINE: So this is great.
I'm showing you guys a
video of me winning, right?
- Florine has to
do the [INAUDIBLE].
HANS FLORINE: Of course, what
else is he going to show?
- [INAUDIBLE] can only hope that
it's Hans Florine that misses
the buzzer this year.
- And Hans Florine with a
signature double dyno move
takes a one length lead.
[CHEERING]
HANS FLORINE: So
this was like 1997.
Or it's '96.
- It's all Florine.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
HANS FLORINE: I've
got to tell you
that I've never used a double
hand dyno on El Capitan.
It's strictly for
the show of the game.
Part of why I've been able to do
the ascent 100 times-- and I'm
just gesturing over
here, but why on earth
would I do it 100 times?
Part of it was the
culture started
accepting what we were doing.
I wouldn't really
stretch it that you
could make a living climbing
because I was a yuppie
and I had other
ways to make money.
But it was the
culture [INAUDIBLE]
But this is the
culture of Camp Four.
And why I put this photo
up is that in 2000,
Camp Four was at risk of being
plowed under because we had
the 100 year flood in 1999,
and housing got wiped out,
and they were going to
build apartments here.
And so we got the Camp
Four campground put
on the historic
register, and climbers
came from around the world, not
just the state or the country,
around the world, and gathered
to celebrate this being
put on the historic register.
And they said hey,
if you'd climbed
in the 90s, the
last decade, come up
and get your picture taken.
So I got to come up.
This is me with my big
golden locks of hair.
And then they said come on
up and get your picture taken
if you'd climbed in the 80s.
And I came up then,
because I'd climbed.
Some people came up twice.
Some people came up three times.
Some people came up four
times and some people
came up five times.
They had climbed
all those decades,
and I thought that was
so cool, the longevity
in the sport of these people
climbing, or the activity.
They didn't really
call it a sport.
So I remember vividly, my
first time in Camp Four.
I'm coming from
my car to my thing
and I have climbing gear on,
and this guy comes up to me
really fast and he's like
hey, what did you do today?
And I didn't know this
guy, and I'm like well,
we climbed this route
called the Nutcracker over
on Manure Pile Buttress.
And he's like, wow,
that's truly great.
Did you guys free climb it?
I'm like well, I fell
on one of the pitches.
My buddy got all
the pitches free.
And he's like, that is so cool.
How long did it take you?
I time everything now
from diaper changes
to climbing rocks,
but back then I
didn't and I'm like well, we
started at 8:00 this morning
and it's three.
So I don't know, it took
like five or six hours.
He's like hey, that's so cool.
Good job.
Yeah, awkward silence.
Like He just stood there.
I'm like, oh, I
know, he wants me
to ask him what he did today.
So I'm like, hey,
what did you do today?
And he's like, we climbed
this new route over
on [INAUDIBLE] up this
crack and it's super scary,
and my buddy on site
free climbed it.
He was so psyched to
pat me on the back
and then burn me off with
something a little better.
I don't know if you guys have
that culture here or what,
but I thought that
was very cool that he
was kind of encouraging,
but he wanted you
to ask him what he had done.
So I'm going to go through
the history of just the nose
route, the most famous big
wall route in the world.
After the first ascent,
the second ascent in 1960,
they did it in Alpine
style, which means
they didn't fix ropes all over.
They just started at the bottom,
went to the top in seven days.
The second ascent, like
wow, that can be done.
So it was done in
three and a half days.
And by 1975, probably oh, 25,
30 teams had climbed the route,
but they did it in a single day,
and they coined this phrase,
nose in a day, or NYAD.
In fact my license
plate is love NYAD.
This was pretty amazing because
they're still using pitons back
then.
By the late 80s, it was
a feather in your cap.
I don't know, maybe like a
CPA if you're an accountant.
But if you haven't
done NYAD, you're
not a competent trad climber.
But what was interesting is
that an Austrian and a German
held the speed
record on the nose
and I didn't think that was
right, although my name's Hans.
I'm a melting pot American.
So I asked Steve Schneider,
also a melting pot American,
if he would go for the
record on the nose with me.
And he didn't know me.
He was like the John
McEnroe of climbing.
I was a nobody, but he
said, OK because he was
worried I'd do it without him.
Well, we climbed it in
eight hours and five minutes
and I'm just like, yes.
I'm going to be a
famous climber now.
I got the record
of Steve Schneider
on the most famous big
wall route in the world.
Well, one week later,
Peter Croft and Dave Shultz
did it in 6:40.
These guys were immortal.
Everybody went like this.
These guys are the dream team.
No one will ever
break that time.
And this was in the New York
Times, and the Denver Post,
and the LA Times, and the
San Francisco Chronicle.
No mention of Steve or
Hans, just Peter and Dave.
And we truly thought
this was amazing, an hour
and 25 minutes faster than us.
Well, the following spring,
I ran into Andy Puvell,
which towered over me
six inches, and I'm 6'1".
He's a giant.
We used to trade places
every month in these comps.
I'd beat him one time,
he'd beat me another time.
I went up to Andy and
I'm like hey, Andy,
how about we climb
together outside so people
don't think we're archrivals?
And Andy's like yeah, let's go.
Let's go up to Yosemite
and let's get on the nose.
OK.
So we get on the nose and just
for a lark, we timed ourselves
and we beat the immortals.
We did it in 6:01.
Just like yes.
I called my mom.
I said mom, get ready
to buy the newspaper.
Well, one week later,
[LAUGHTER]
Peter and Dave, 4:48.
I mean imagine, that would
be like taking 20 seconds
off the mile time, right?
An hour and 13 minutes
faster than us.
Everybody went like this.
These guys are the dream team.
No one will ever
break that time.
Crazy.
So the following spring
I got really smart.
This is Peter Croft.
I went to a slideshow
given by Peter Croft.
After the slide
show go, hey, Peter.
Good job on climbing the nose.
[MUMBLES]
Good job on all this
other stuff you're doing.
Hey, Peter-- he didn't know me
that well and I'm like, Peter,
would you climb with
me sometime so people
don't think we're archrivals?
He's like, no.
And I'm all turning
red, like really?
But he said, just kidding.
I don't care what people think.
Let's go climbing.
So we go to Yosemite we're like,
what are we going to climb?
He goes, I don't know.
Let's call him the nose.
So we climb the nose in
4:22, and everyone goes oh!
Well, I didn't call my mom.
I said, I'm going to wait a
week and see what happens.
Because I don't
know, I figured--
a week goes by.
We still have the record.
A month goes by.
We still have it.
A year goes by.
We still have the record.
Well, all the press
we like, you guys
break the record every year.
It's not news.
So we got a little postage
size stamp thing in the letter
to the editor.
They broke the record again.
[SIGHS]
No fame for Hans.
Well, nine years went by and
the new young dream team,
Timmy O'Neill and Dean
Potter got the record
with all the new
tools and stuff.
They broke the four hour mark.
I thought it would be really
cool if one week later, someone
broke their records.
So I call all of my friends.
Let's go up there and
get the record, right?
And all my friends
are married with kids
and working 50 hours a week.
But there's this guy, Jim Herson
who's just a total stud rock
climber.
Anybody here know Jim?
He's a member here at Sunnyvale.
So he goes, I can't go next
week, but in two weeks I can.
Go so Jim Herson sends
me a picture of him
training to climb the nose.
Get in trouble with the
parents authorities, here.
So to our amazement,
two dads off the couch,
we do it in 3:57.
We just slide underneath and
get it, just by sheer whatever.
Well, Dean and Timmy being
young and disrespectful,
they didn't let
us keep the record
for a month or even a week.
Two days later they went
up and did it in 3:24,
and everyone went like this.
These guys are the
new dream team.
No one will ever
break that record.
Hans stay home, and
raise kids, and do a job.
They were right.
So they kept the
record for a week.
They kept it for a month.
They kept it for a year.
The next year, my good
friend Yuji Hirayama
shows up to the US.
He wanted to climb the
Salathe route, which
is another route on El Cap,
and he wanted to do it free.
And I said hey, Yuji, let's
do the nose kind of as warm
up to get used to the granite.
You climb in the
southeast, you want
to get used to the sandstone.
You want to climb here, you
get used to the granite.
So to me and Yuji's amazement,
our very first time trying
the nose in a day, we did it in
3:27, which was not the record,
but we passed seven
parties along the way.
It's a pretty busy route
and I wrote the book
on speed climbing.
There's a whole
chapter designated
to the art of passing.
You've got to stop and
say hello to people
and ask permission pass.
So I figured we should get a one
minute handicap for each party
we pass and we should
have the record,
but that didn't
really go over well.
So we went back the
next week and Yuji
had some friends go to the top
of El Cap and film down on us.
So I'm just going
to play this footage
because it's pretty unique.
I don't even think
Google sidewalk
or whatever it's
called has this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[HELICOPTER SOUNDS ABOVE]
Street View, that's
what it's called, right?
We did not have the budget
for a helicopter, by the way.
There was a rescue
going on that day.
Hey, and while
this is playing, I
got you guys lock solid
until 1:00, right?
I can give you
stories until then?
All right.
I don't know if this
auditorium, has motion sickness
bags under the seat, but
this is kind of big here,
so be careful.
So this is pretty
amazing, you guys,
this is not a broccoli
patch up there.
Those are full size pine
trees and today, that picture,
80% of that is brown from
bark beetles and the drought.
Not to make an eco statement,
just an interesting thing,
the change.
This is his photographer,
Kenji, jumping in and out
to take the shot.
So the very last part of El
Cap is this roof, right here,
that Yuji's going to cup
under, and then you crest over,
and then you run like
80 feet to this tree
where you stop your time.
And Yuji is up there, and he's
pulling the rope up on me,
and all these people are down in
the meadow yelling like crazy.
And their voices get lifted
up because of the air currents
and we're super psyched
because we can hear them.
And I'm exhausted
trying to keep up
with Yuji, totally
exhausted, but excited
these people yelling at me.
So I want to like yell
something back down at them,
but I'm going anaerobic and
have almost no air left.
And here's the best I can
do back towards the people
down below.
[SHOUTING]
[LAUGHTER]
Just focus on getting
to the top, Hans.
So the week before, we
did it in three hours
and 27 minutes, which was three
minutes shy of the record.
This week there was
nobody on the route
and we actually did it in
two hours and 48 minutes.
That's like Moore's law
in two weeks, basically.
But everybody went like
this, it's the dream team
and no one will ever
break that record.
So Yuji is not only like
this world class climber,
he's won the world
championships dozens of times.
He's a super world-class,
funny, friendly guy.
If you don't speak Japanese, you
can read some English subtitles
underneath.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[SHOUTING]
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, fun guy.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So this was amazing.
There was a crowd of
people in the meadow.
And so we get back
down to the forest
and there's somebody
poking a camera in my face,
and I'm happy to talk.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
HANS FLORINE (YOUNG):
I feel really happy.
I think it's going to be
really hard for someone
to go faster than us.
Yeah, unless there's like
two Yujis going up together.
It would be really hard.
I think this record will
last for a good long time.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
HANS FLORINE: So that
was fun, finally I
got the definitive record,
and this is kind of
like my gear talk, tech talk
picture for climbers and stuff.
But we actually
finally got press.
I got on the front cover
of Climber Magazine.
It's funny that Ali said
that I'm really humble.
My nickname was Hollywood Hans.
Nothing could be less
humble than that, right?
So we got all this press, and
worldwide, the nose kind of
gained more--
I don't know-- significance
in the climbing community.
And actual
professional climbers,
Alex and Thomas Huber, got
rumored a million dollar
filming budget to come and
do a documentary on getting
the record on the nose.
And I went down to the
house they were staying,
and brought my kids,
and I was trying
to show him my little CD set
on how to climb the nose faster
and stuff.
And they're busy trying to
have my kids drink alcohol
like good Germans.
They're like no, no,
we just go faster.
It turns out they won all
these awards for the film
because it was this
cool drama and whatever,
but they didn't get
the record in the film.
Super proud, they came
back the next year
and got the record on the
nose, off film, I guess.
But if a picture is
worth a thousand words,
a video is worth a
thousand pictures.
These guys are hilarious.
I'll just let this play.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In 2007, the nose race was
shaken up by German climbing
stars Alex and Thomas Huber.
- First, we thought speed
climbing is a stupid thing.
Or it's an Americans thing.
I don't want to say American and
it's the same like stupid but--
HANS FLORINE: But
I just did, yeah.
- --we don't like it.
- But we found out that it's
real sport, and we like sports,
and of course we're ambitious,
and we want to do this.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
HANS FLORINE: Hilarious.
Alex and Thomas Huber
are very cool guys.
Just the classic, we
got the record shot.
They beat the record
only by 20 seconds,
and then they went
back three days later,
and chopped a full
three minutes off it.
So very proud.
When people would say
like oh, the record
will never be broken.
No one's ever going to
break you and Yuji's record.
I'd be like, no way,
and I'm a big wagerer.
I'm like, I'll bet
you $100 that somebody
is going to break our record.
And sure enough,
when they broke it,
my buddy, Bob, sent
me a $100 check.
So I used it to go buy
beers for Thomas and Alex.
It wasn't enough for
them, but I tried.
So I got beta from
them on how to--
beta means ideas.
That's an old term you
guys probably don't know.
But ideas how to go faster.
And that very next spring,
me and Yuji show up,
and hundreds of people are in
the meadow, cheering us on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CHEERING]
Here's a little
footage from that.
- Go!
Go!
[CHEERING CONTINUES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HANS FLORINE: So
I'm so exhausted,
I can't tell them what time it
is, whether we got the record.
- 2:43:33.
[SHOUTS]
HANS FLORINE: Still
out of breath.
I'm trying to talk.
- Yeah!
HANS FLORINE: And of
course, we get the full
on NASCAR greeting down--
- What time did you get, hun?
- 2:43:33.
[EXUBERANT CHEERING]
HANS FLORINE: Yeah, here's the
NASCAR greeting in the woods
when we get down.
[CHEERING]
- Yeah, right.
That's good.
- We're going to go
break that record.
So you guys watch out.
We are going to break that.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
HANS FLORINE: Remember
those words, you guys.
Someone's going to
break that record.
So again, my little
tech talk here.
So I was in college.
I went to Cal Poly
San Luis Obispo.
Me and my roommate came
up in 1988 by headlamp.
We hiked to the base,
here in the woods,
and we started climbing,
and we climbed all day
until it got dark.
Well, it was just
dusk, and we're like,
we're not going to make it.
We've drank more
than half our water.
And we were kind of
planning on a two or three
day ascent, like most people
do, and we're not going it.
We drank more than
half our water,
ate more than half our
food, and after that 13, 14
hours of climbing, we
arrived right here.
And we repelled down, went
back to school for a year,
and came back, and we climbed
route in three days a year
later.
But when me and Yuji then--
let's see, 18 years later.
I was 26 when I came and it
took me 14 hours to get here.
18 years later, when I was
old and feeble, but more
knowledgeable, me and
Yuji took 17 minutes
to get to Sickle Ledge,
which is some sort of Moore's
law in there of some
sort or another.
So really cool perspective.
When I'm speaking around,
people come up to me years
later and say, I was
inspired to do this or that.
I kind of point out, I don't
save lives in Ethiopia,
per se, directly or whatever,
but because I've kind of
focused on something
so tightly, I've
gotten all these
cool invitations
to do different things.
And one of them I just
wanted to share with you is I
have had the good
fortune or the honor
to climb with Erik Weihenmayer,
who is a blind climber who's
done the seven summits.
He asked me, in the
mid 90s, if a blind guy
could climb the nose of El
Cap and I'm like, yeah, sure.
Because I was
young and ignorant,
I didn't know to say no to him,
and we ended up climbing it.
And for those that don't know--
climbers know this, but on most
big walls, a leader goes up,
and then the
followers go on rope.
Either you're pulling
the rope up for them,
or you're sliding an ascender
like this up the rope
and then it can't come down.
And so maybe even
you guys would think,
well, I'd rather be blind if I'm
3,000 feet up so that I'm not
scared of the exposure.
All Erik did was follow
Hans up the rope.
He just slid his jugs up there.
And then I tell people
that Erik actually
led some of the pitches,
which means he went up first,
tied the rope, and then
I had to follow him.
They're Like Hans,
you're stupid.
How did you survive that?
But totally incredible,
impressive guy, Erik.
I've gotten to adventure with
him a couple of other times.
He invited me to go do Mount
Kenya with him, which is not
the tallest peak in the
continent of Africa,
it's the second tallest.
He'd already done Kilimanjaro
and he said hey, come and do
this because it's like
this big granite wall.
So this is a shot of Erik and
Charlie in Heathrow Airport.
And Erik's got his white cane
under his lap, right here.
Erik came to San Francisco
with his seeing eye dog
and did a show.
He's a motivational speaker.
And then I was going
to meet him there
and I would be
his seeing eye dog
to get him to Heathrow
Airport, where he'd be reunited
with Charlie and his stick.
So we had this little trick.
Erik would just kind of hold
onto a backpack, back here,
and he'd just be back at my 4
o'clock or maybe my 7 o'clock
because we're going
through the airport,
and you'd never know he's blind.
And we're late for
our flight, as usual.
And I go and I cut the
corner on this table,
and I forgot Erik
was back there.
Erik hits the table
right at the wrong spot,
doubles over on the ground.
I'm like, how am I going
to get him up Mount Kenya?
I can't even get him
through an airport.
Just crazy.
So we're sitting in
first class because Erik
has all these miles, and
I'm probably going to go off
the screen, so I can't do that.
But OK, so I'm sitting
in first class,
and back behind me is Erik
in his first class seat.
And for those of you who've
never flown first class,
they give you a little
menu and ask you
what you want before
the plane takes off.
Well, this was 19--
no, this was 2005.
He actually had a
CD player, Erik did,
and he was listening
to books on tape,
and he had his earplugs in, and
he's looking at his CD player,
like this.
The Steward comes up and
places the menu right
in front of his face.
She says sir, what would
you like for dinner?
He can't hear her and he
can't see that there's
a menu in front of his face.
And he doesn't have
dark glasses on,
but he has these
fake glass eyes,
and they look really nice.
And she just gets
louder, and louder.
And I'm up here, and I hear
this woman yelling, sir,
what do you want for dinner?
Sir what do you want for dinner?
And I'm like oh, sorry
ma'am, he can't see.
And she just starts
yelling, why didn't you
tell me he can't see?
I'm like, I didn't know I
had to announce to everybody.
And like here I am, oh my
god, how can I get this guy.
So quite amazing just
all the little things
we take for granted
just getting places.
So I think green is
approximately Kilimanjaro
and red is Kenya.
So Erik sends me this beautiful
picture of Mount Kenya,
and he wants me to do this 1,900
foot granite face when there's
perfectly good ridge
line to do over there,
but he wants to do the hard way.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
And when Erik's approaching,
we're talking and stuff.
When our voices get tired,
we have a little jingle bell,
reindeer bell that we jingle
on the back of the packs.
And it's just kind
of business as usual.
You'd never know he's
blind because he's just
feeling his way with his poles.
I think off here on
the left skyline,
you'll see-- we were
like a day into the hike
and we have another day
before we get to base camp.
You can see Mount Kenya shows
up here in the far left corner
there.
So a long ways to go.
This is Erik coming
down a talus slope.
We went up and set gear at
the beginning of the route,
that 1,900 foot granite
face, and then we
had to go back down this
to get to base camp.
Now, me and Charlie probably
could have gone down
this talus slope in
less than 15 minutes,
but with Erik, it was probably
just less than two hours.
Imagine the pool goes
between two rocks,
so you think it's a
three foot drop off,
but it's actually only
a one foot drop off.
Or the reverse could happen.
He thinks it's a one foot, but
his foot goes next to a pole.
Just arduous amount of work.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
We heard that there
was a European hut
on top of this thing.
So we started at 4:00 AM,
topped out at like 10:00 PM,
and there was a hut, all
right, but it was more
an aluminum coffin.
It was this tall
and it was 5'11".
I know because I'm 6'1", and I
couldn't quite straighten out
in it.
So we slept like a four
hour sleepless night
there and hiked on down.
So Erik, he doesn't want to take
the easy route up this thing.
He also doesn't want
to do normal stuff
when he's in a foreign country.
So he's like, what
do tourists do
that's kind of weird in Africa?
And somebody planted
the seed in his head
that people go and
ride ostriches.
Anybody here ridden an ostrich?
I have, but there's
one thing Erik
can't do is as
adventuresome as he
is, he can't film for nothing.
When he filmed me on
the ostrich, all you see
is the feet going by.
But we do have footage
of him actually on it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
And these handlers have to
be on the side, no matter
whether you're sighted or not.
And Erik's always game.
You got to do it styling,
and we're like Erik,
it doesn't count unless you
wave your hand over your head.
So he's totally game to
do whatever we tell him.
HANS FLORINE (ON
VIDEO): Very well done.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
HANS FLORINE: So some
of the fun adventures
I've gotten to go on.
But I want to go back
to my neighborhood
and finish off with a story
here of something that's
happened here.
Anybody know the name,
or two guys names,
that first ascended Everest?
Throw it out if you want.
AUDIENCE: Edmund
Hillary and [INAUDIBLE].
HANS FLORINE: Correct.
Edmund Hillary and
Tenzing Norgay.
Does anybody know who has the
fastest ascent of Everest?
Yes, dead silence.
And the reason I
point that out is
that I had the fastest time on
the nose and the fastest time
on Half Dome [INAUDIBLE]
but people in the climbing
community, and somewhat
in outside world,
whoever's the first to
do something gets fame,
and we all want that.
Well, I do.
Or you do something
that's just totally--
no one thought to
do it beforehand.
So in 1986, John
Becker and Peter Croft
at midnight on a full moon,
they started right here--
excuse me.
Is that where they started?
No, they started right
here, on their bikes.
They biked up to the end of
the valley, they hiked over,
they climbed Half Dome.
The face of Half Dome, a
grade 6 route, which today,
an average party takes
two days to climb.
They climbed it in like
10 hours or so or less,
hiked down, got on the bikes,
biked to this into the valley,
climbed El Cap, wend
down the [INAUDIBLE],
got on their bikes, and went
to the Mountain Room Bar
in the same 24 hours.
What?
Everyone went like this.
This was called The Linkup.
The Linkup.
One week later, nobody
repeated this feat.
Two years later, nobody.
Five years later--
it was 10 years later
before someone successfully
was able to repeat
this feat, The Linkup.
I'm like, maybe I could do
something first that's fast.
So around round about
the late 90s, only--
and myself included-- only
four teams total in the world
had done The Linkup.
So what's the next thing to do?
Well, let me explain.
When two people go up a big
wall, it's inchworm climbing.
First person goes up, second
person cleans the gear
and meet, and then
the person goes up,
second person cleans
has gear and meet.
And they might
switch who's leading,
but it's an inch worm thing.
You go a rope length at a time.
So when you climb by
yourself up a big wall,
you place the rope at
the base, you climb up,
and now you're up on
this ledge or anchor,
and there's nobody there
to clean your gear.
So you have to repel down,
get your rucksack if you're
European, or backpack
if you're American,
and you put your jugs on.
You ascend back up to
here and then you repeat.
You go up again, repel down.
So when you solo
a big wall route,
you actually climb it
twice, and repel it once.
Kind of like sand dune hiking.
You go up three
steps, slide back two.
So why would anybody solo?
Anybody?
Because you have no friends.
But it turns out to be
a pretty proud thing
in climbing to solo big
walls or to solo mountains.
So it's a thing that's done.
Well, I wanted to
be the first person
to solo The Linkup, the two
grade sixes in the valley.
I heard that winter that
this guy, Dean Potter,
had climbed this route
in 4 hours and 17 minutes
by himself.
And I'm like oh, I've
climbed this route by myself
in 14 hours, so that's 18.
So that's under 24, but of
course, you're exhausted.
It's like saying you're going to
run a marathon in the morning,
whatever.
But I got it in my head,
I'm going to do this.
And I'd call it accountability
partners, this was 1999.
As best I could, I
emailed out a bunch.
Told everyone I'm going to do it
and committed to the full moon,
July 24.
I'm going to go do
this thing and I went,
and I climbed Half
Dome in the morning.
I started at 4:30 AM, and
to my utter amazement,
I beat the immortal, crazy
climber, Dean Potter.
I beat it by like 20 minutes.
I climbed it in
under four hours.
I came around down
by, I think 11:00 AM,
I arrived in El Cap
Meadow and my good friend,
Steve Schneider was there,
who I talked about earlier.
He's my number one
fan by this point
because he's known
me for awhile.
If I tie my shoe fast,
Steve Schneider's
like good job, Hans, way to go.
So I was psyched to tell
my best buddy and mentor,
Steve Schneider, I got
the record on Half Dome
that morning.
And he knew, along with the
rest of the climbing community,
I was trying to do
The Linkup that day.
And so I go, Steve
I just got to record
on Half Dome and Steve's
like good job, Hans.
Kind of hanging his head.
And I'm like, Steve,
aren't you excited for me?
I mean, I just got to record.
I'm going to do The Linkup.
I'm going to be the first
person to do The Linkup
and he's like, Hans, I
got to tell you something
I don't want to tell you.
I'm like, what is it?
Spit it out man.
He's like Dean Potter
flew here yesterday
and did The Linkup, both
routes in a day, before you.
He kind of hovers down
like I'm going to hit him
and I'm just like oh,
that's totally awesome.
Oh, it's not awesome.
I'm not going to be the first.
So that was hard.
I went from the
highest of highs to oh,
and I thought I was going
to be climbing El Cap.
I didn't have anything else to
do that afternoon and Steve was
trying to break the ice.
He goes hey, how about we go and
get an ice cream or something.
I'm like, no.
I've kind of got
it in my head, I'm
going to just go and
start climbing El Cap.
So I walk to the base
and start climbing,
and it gets dark about
when I'm halfway up,
and I put on a headlamp,
and I keep climbing.
And there's these big
ledges that you get to,
and I got to the ledge
called Camp Five.
There's somebody there that kept
me awake because I'm climbing.
And then I got to Camp 6
and Mark Wellman was there.
Middle of the night, it's
1:00 AM in the morning.
He's paralyzed from
the waist down.
It's his second time up El Cap.
How motivational, right?
Middle of the night.
I arrive there and Mark
Wellman's like dude, Hans,
what are doing?
He's getting out
of his sleeping bag
or sitting up in a sleeping bag.
What are you doing, man?
And I'm like, Mark man--
by this time, I'm
kind of excited
and I've gotten over the whole
thing, I'm not the first.
I'm just like hey, two
guys get to the moon.
It's still cool to be the first
two guys to walk on the moon.
This is incredible.
So whatever in my head.
I'm like Mark, I'm psyched that
I'm climbing El Cap and Half
Dome in a day by myself.
And Mark's like
really, do you know
that Dean Potter was
through here last night
doing the same thing?
I'm just like can't you think of
something original to do, Hans?
So I just kind of kept
climbing through the night.
I got near the top
and my good friend,
Alard Hufner from South Africa,
had hiked the top of Half Dome,
and hiked to the top of El
Cap to photo and film me.
And here he is, after 21
hours of hiking and climbing,
he just meets me with this big
old smile, and I'm exhausted,
and the best I could do
back to him was this.
This, to me, is the touchstone
picture, if you will,
of the end of the
best day of your life.
You're super
excited, super happy,
maybe not super
energized, but you've
got that feeling of
reward on your face.
I know that 99%
of the time I look
like this, very
humble, Hollywood Hans
and on the front cover of this.
But really, all my
best adventures,
I want to end somewhere
looking like this.
I don't know if it's you
guys have an app deadline
or what it is, and
you're here, and you're
programming in your
rooms to 1:00 AM,
but this is what you
want it to look like.
I mean, just
exhausted and great.
And it's this sort of--
I don't know-- image that
I look back on to try
to-- what's my next adventure?
Well, whatever it is, I want
to look like this at the end.
And that's kind of
what's spurned me on
to all of this numbers
stuff, if you will,
or achieving the 100th ascent
of the nose, or whatever.
I wanted to point out something
else in the culture of climbing
that's kind of neat.
This is Tom Frost, over here,
with the white shirt on.
He started climbing--
pause for effect--
he started climbing
before I was born.
He did the second
ascent of the nose,
and the first ascend the
Salathe, and many other things.
So he started climbing
before I was born.
I've gotten to
climb with him, some
of the great routes in Yosemite.
And then Alex Honnold over
here, is kind of 60 minutes
boy, cover of
National Geographic.
I started climbing
before Alex was born
and I've got to climb
with him as well.
In fact, I got the nose
record with him in 2012
after I had done it with Yuji.
And so I'm just
super grateful, I
guess, for that
sort of connection
between the generations.
Tom Frost, actually--
the old guy-- solo'd
up to the base of the nose
and gave me and Yuji ideas
on how to go faster.
We're taking ideas
from this guy that
climbed in the 60s,
70s, and 80s, as well as
young people giving us ideas.
So I put that out
there that it's great
that the ideas come from
all these different levels
of the experience in climbing.
And I want to end on this story.
This is Yuji, here on
the right, and Tom Frost.
This is the night before we
were going to go for the record.
And Tom Frost is watching
Yuji organize all this gear,
and Tom Frost is
over here like hey,
I'm so psyched for you guys.
I think Mother
Nature and The Rock
is really cheering for you.
I think you guys are going
to get the record tomorrow.
What do you think?
Are you guys going to get 10
minutes off or 15 minutes off?
And Yuji's like yeah.
He knows the legend, Tom
Frost, so he's psyched.
And he's like, yeah man, Tom.
I think we're going to get 10
or 15 minutes off the record.
I'm so psyched.
I think we're going to do it.
I'm so glad you're here
cheering us on and whatnot.
I should switch places, but Tom
is just like oh, that's cool.
That's really awesome, you guys.
And then he's just sitting
there silent like this.
And I know that he's wanted us
to ask him something about what
he's done, So I'm
like, so Tom, you
broke the record on the nose
when you did it, didn't you?
Yeah, yeah.
He's like, yeah, I did.
And I'm like, well, how
much time did you take off?
And he goes we took three
and a half weeks off
the previous best record.
So if there's a lesson
in that, it's humility.
Thank you guys for
listening to my stories.
I got six minutes for Q&A.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: OK, so I can
pass this mic around.
AUDIENCE: So what goals do you
have for the rest of your life?
HANS FLORINE: My
goals right now are
get my 16-year-old
daughter out of high school
and into college, and my
son through middle school
and maybe to high school.
They're pretty odd goals, but in
regard to climbing and fitness
goals, my odd thing is
I just like to stay fit
when an opportunity arrives.
I happen to be doing the
CrossFit Open right now
for my third year.
I bragged that I placed 1,310th
in my age division last year.
But I just try to
find interesting ways
to stay fit in the city in
case I get invited to Mount
Kenya with Erik or something.
I just want to say that
I'm totally comfortable.
I know you guys maybe
you to be in your seat
at 1:00 PM working, or
you need somewhere to go
or whatever, I don't feel like
you're insulting me if you
have to get up and take off.
AUDIENCE: People who speed
run video games play them
a completely different
way than normal people
play them for fun.
They're finding glitches
in little corners
and unintended stuff.
When you speed climb, how do
you see the rock or the route
differently than a normal
human would see it?
HANS FLORINE: I thought that
was going to be like asking me
how I play one of
these rock climbing
video games or something.
It's different on
a route that you've
been on before, like the
Nose, versus a route you
haven't been on.
One of the things I teach
just in regular climbing
is that when you fall, most
people it's their forearms
that's tired, and you'll say,
where is Hans going with this?
But your forearms are
tired because it's usually
your grip strength
because you're
holding on for dear life.
And I go hey, was
your neck tired?
And they're like, my neck?
No, it wasn't tired.
And I go, well, look
around all the time
whenever you're
climbing for solutions.
And that means when
I'm speed climbing,
I'm often not gripping hard
and fast, I'm looking around.
Where can I place my foot
and push with my foot,
or push with my hand
rather than pull?
And a kind of an interesting
social commentary on that
is when I take a couple to--
I teach a lot of people to
climb at a gym or wherever.
When you take a couple to
climb, male and female, I mean.
It doesn't have to be a
couple, but a male and female,
it tends to be that when
everything else is equal,
the woman will out climb the
man because you get to places
climbing or bouldering
and you're like,
I can't get any farther.
What do I do?
Guys tend to go like this,
and look at their bicep,
and pull harder.
I mean, I exaggerate, but women
tend to go like this and look.
Oh, I can put my foot up.
Or oh, I can grab
this undecling.
And so when I'm
speed climbing, I'm
like oh, my necks' not tired.
I'm going to look around.
What can I do?
You're a little bit
frantic, but more--
I like urgent better than--
frantic sounds so much better.
AUDIENCE: So each time that you
went to beat a previous record,
was there something that
you added in training or--
I mean, you mentioned that
you would be more aware?
But is there something
that you would work on
to be faster in the previous
time, in particular?
HANS FLORINE: Great question.
Once the Huber brothers
got the record,
Me and Yuji actually
started looking at the topos
and plotting out
let's lead this,
and we never used this
piece of gear, here.
Tom Frost was
really good at hey,
there's a logistical
point where a crack ends
and you have to pendulum
over to another.
And how you decide who's
going to pendulum low and high
can save you time,
and someone doesn't
have to climb this
terrain or that terrain.
So we would actually
sit there on the topo,
and draw it out, and start
planning versus let's just
go faster.
Those guys did more
than just go faster.
But that's one of
the big change was
strategy wise, we just really
took a close look at hey,
are we wasting time
coiling the rope up here
and somebody climbs
this part twice?
But as a training part, I
was working at an architect
engineering firm
when me and Yuji
got the record [INAUDIBLE].
I would get up at 4:00
AM, climb for three hours
because I knew the record
would be at three hours,
as hard as I could in the
gym, and go into my cubicle
all exhausted for
the rest of the day.
And I'd do that
twice a week maybe.
So I was just training
for the time period
that I'd be putting
out effort, I guess,
or what I thought I'd
be putting out effort.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
definitely not planning
on climbing The
Nose this season,
or anytime in the
next couple of years,
but I feel like I speak
for a lot of people in here
that are aspirational big wall
climbers, or aspirational just
climbers in general.
What tips you would have for
people that are intermediate,
trying to get
better in the sport,
and especially
trying to balance--
you mentioned you had
other ways of living.
I don't know if you
had a full time job
and you had to balance
climbing with that job.
HANS FLORINE: Well,
right out of college
I went and worked
50 hours a week
at a manufacturing
and engineering
firm with a tie and slacks.
I was working 50 hours a
week, but every Tuesday,
Thursday after work, I'd be
bouldering around the city.
I was in LA and then I'd go
out to the desert Joshua Tree
and climb my brains
out every weekend,
and be exhausted Monday.
I was in love with the
activity of climbing.
But to your other question,
wherever you're at in climbing,
how do you get to
doing big walls?
Go and do a multi-pitch
route in Lover's Leap,
like two, or three,
or four pitches
so you learn how to, for
one, go up trad cracks,
and then you add an anchor,
and now you go up another.
Because in the gyms, of
course it's never multi-pitch.
So just that organization
of how to move
urgently, and quickly,
and safely, of course.
Different pitches,
and then you go,
well, let's go do an overnight
on a long route in Yosemite,
and then let's do a
two-day thing or something.
There's a road to the Nose by
Chris McNamara on super topo.
There, I plugged you, Chris.
Supertopo.com, Road to the Nose.
It tells you all the routes to
do on up to doing a big wall.
AUDIENCE: If somebody goes and
breaks the record next week,
are you going to be
out there in two weeks?
HANS FLORINE: I will not go
and break the record again.
A handful of public
audiences I've--
accountability partners, you
guys, I'm not going to go back.
Not for that record, yeah.
Yeah, back in the back.
AUDIENCE: How much more
traffic has the Nose gotten
over the years, is
my first question,
and the second one
is how many times
have you climbed the Nose.
HANS FLORINE: Now it's been 103
times I've climbed the route,
and I've repelled it twice.
I forgot to put
that stat in there.
That's pretty fun.
About the crowdedness of
the Nose, it's interesting.
There's no permit
required to climb El Cap.
You can just go and climb.
It's an old grandfathered thing
about climbers and wilderness.
We're allowed climb big walls.
So you never know how
many people will be on it,
but when I climbed it in
1998, we passed nine parties.
Not people, but parties.
So there could have been two to
four people in those parties.
I've never claimed it since then
with that many parties on it.
El Capitan as a whole,
you could look up
on a starry night
at dusk and there'll
be three dozen headlamps here,
and then the stars above it.
It's a totally cool scene.
So if you're ever in Yosemite,
go at dusk at climbing season.
But that is limited to the
four to six weeks in the spring
and four to five
weeks in the fall.
If you go, there'll be nobody
on El from summer solstice,
June to the 1st of
September because people
tend to think it's too hot.
We're really gifted
here in the Bay Area.
We can look at the
weather report.
I look at my watch,
I don't know why.
Look at the weather report and
go, oh, it's cool this weekend.
I can go.
You could go up El Cap
and there's nobody on it,
especially as a Bay Area person,
or if you have a private jet.
AUDIENCE: How do
you deal with fear
and have you had a bad fall?
HANS FLORINE: I have
had numerous bad falls.
My worst was a broken--
I slammed my face into the rock
and broke front teeth and rope
burn on my leg.
That one happened so fast.
There's a sport climbing
fall where I just flipped up
and probably it was
only fell like 25 feet
and slammed my face.
There wasn't time to be afraid.
But I've had falls
where I've slid down
slopes of granite 45 feet, and
I'm just like the whole time,
probably screaming.
This is before you had mobile
phones to record this stuff.
And my hands were burned, and
actually, my knees were burned.
I was frog laying on
it, trying to get grip.
I said at the beginning,
often at mainstream talks--
I don't know what that
qualifies as-- but I'll
explain I'm not the m-word.
I'm not a mountaineer,
which tends to be more risk.
And most deaths in climbing
is mountaineering alpinism.
Although, I've tried
that type climbing,
and it's fun and
adventurous, I'm
a t-shirt and shorts climber.
I love the athleticism of
covering all this ground
on El Cap.
And so when I get scared or
fearful, I look to end it.
Like oh my gosh, I'm 10
feet above my last piece
of protection.
What can I do right now to put
something in so I'm not afraid?
Kind of like when
your deadline--
I don't know, I'll
try to tie it in.
Deadline for your
app is due and you're
like bring in some more
help, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: So my question.
In the book, "50
Favorite Climbs,"
you said that Beggars Buttress
was your favorite route.
HANS FLORINE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that still
your favorite line?
HANS FLORINE: That never
was my favorite climb,
but the author of the
book, "50 Favorite,"
said you cannot choose any route
that's in the 50 classics book.
So right across the valley
from Beggars Buttress
is a beautiful view of the Nose.
So the route he talks
about, Beggars Buttress,
ends right here, actually.
So you're looking
right over at the Nose.
AUDIENCE: I listened to
an interview with you
where you talked a
lot about bringing
a lot of other
climbers up El Cap.
Can you just talk
about maybe some
of the best stories you have of
bringing other climbers up El
Cap?
HANS FLORINE: If I
tell you the best
stories of bringing
other climbers up El Cap,
nobody will read the book.
How's that?
One of the chapters
is completely
published in "Rock and
Ice," and it's probably
most known for me as that's the
speed record with Alex Honnold.
He's a very funny,
charming young man.
But one of the most memorable
is Erik Weihenmayer,
the blind guy.
We were five days on the
route and that he led pitches,
I would never consider
having him lead pitches now
that I know what I know.
I was just ignorant back then.
And I remember him
leading up this crack that
was of the same size for 100
feet, I'm thinking, oh great,
it's the same size.
He can just keep feeling
his hands the same
and placing gear.
But I'm down there belaying and
I only gave him three number
two Camelot's, which is
the right size for that,
and he's placed the three,
and he has none left,
and he still has
70 feet to climb.
And I'm down there belying just
going, what have I just done?
What have I just done?
I set this blind guy up to
either die or fall a long way
and be maimed for life,
more so than he is.
And just other
memories on that trip.
I broke down and cried on top.
I was so exhausted from
guiding him up there,
which I use the term
now guided, but I
realized when I got to the
top, I didn't guide him.
He led us to do this thing.
He's an amazing leader.
You guys got to be careful
because I can Q&A for 10 hours
because I just love
what I'm doing.
But most people, because it's
the Everest of rock climbing,
they will do it once
and they'll remember
it the rest of their life.
And that, to me, is just
this crazy fun rewarding bond
that I was with them.
And so it's so cool
to go up that route
with different
people, whether it's
famous Lin Hill or I don't
know, John Smith from Belgium,
or whatever.
Yeah, it's cool to be
part of their memory.
SPEAKER: Let's just give Hans
another round of applause for--
[APPLAUSE]